tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nome
io sono quello che fa le reaction delle
cose nipponiche ora vi spiego mi sta
tornando la voglia del giappone nel
senso io una volta l'anno vado in
giappone questa cosa mi sa che la sapete
tutti perché faccio sempre blog però
ogni anno che passa
io cosa faccio torna dal giappone e poi
tornava giappone che sono staturo del
giappone sono stato lì in tre settimane
sempre ogni volta su altra settimana poi
passa un po di tempo e in questo priori
tempo mi ritorna la voglia del giappone
quindi l'anno dopo quando ritorno in
giappone sono con la voglia mille di
torna lì ma perché mi è tornata così
presto visto che ci sono andato ad
aprile perché sto guardando gli spot
pubblicitari giapponesi da almeno
quattro video che avete visto torniamo
sulle fantastiche reaction pubblicità
giapponesi che come sempre sono 10 volte
meglio che quelle italiane
oggi speriamo di trovare un qualche cosa
di poco kringe non scherzo voglio il
green già manetta velocità allora si
parte è una classe ragazzi ditemi voi se
non sembrava il meme quello dei neri che
con il tipo si butta fango era la stessa
cosa in versione giapponese però luglio
joel installano pubblicità un sacco
dell'inps
amici tifo una marca di dolci yogurt
bonus
però ogni volta che entrò nei combini
che io sono qui gli store 24 ore su 24
aperti nel reparto dolci trova rob amici
ora questo che questa macchina io non è
la pubblicità di che cosa del rame anche
quelle di noodle istantanei usuri petra
no fermi tutti scusatemi ma perché la
pubblicità vero perché la pubblicità di
noodle istantanee mi entry cola
decappottabile che problemi cosa io
quando vado dal mio migliore amico e
sfoggia un vestito nuovo
abbiamo capito andiamo avanti
che cos'è
ma perché bellissima la pausa tempo
comico perfetto perfetto
meraviglioso complimenti non so
basterebbe scusate un attimo ma poi tra
l'altro questa cosa che non ho capito ma
loro vendono i nudi ramen che tifa inca
c'è il rame non è difficilissimo da
cucina e questa cosa non l'ho mai capita
giuro che la prossima tappa di un
giappone mi compro del ramen take away
perché voglio capire come è fatto perché
il rame ragazzi difficilissimo da fare
bene
quindi io non so come sia possibile che
vengano al rame nella scatoletta bonato
è dichiaratamente scadente oppure
borioso comunque lo compro e lo provo
perché io sono pazzo del ramo in però
quello fatto ben cortesemente datemi
anche lei da oggi esistono i backstreet
boys e giapponesi o forse no va bene va
bene dove arriviamo
e perché ci hanno vestito attuati più
quanti bravi
faisal and dragons e no roba tipo candy
cresce a chi cospira infine pubblicità
in giappone dove la gente si avvicina
qualcosa la bocca il rallenty come se
fosse non ho mai capito perché
fettuccine gulli signori fettuccine
fettuccine perché in america ci sono le
fettuccine alfredo che sono alfredo papa
della fettuccine qua ci sono le
fettuccine gumi cene stesso loro ti
mettono le fettuccine dentro le carabine
zucchero lo provate un sacco di volte le
vendono sempre ne combini universal
studios ci sono stato ragazzi universal
studios in giappone sono sveglio questa
è forse l'unica pubblicità che azzeccato
tra all'inizio l'unica presenza che
dovrei fare questo questa cosa di
azzecca la pubblicità all'inizio però
secondo il professor layton
non so perché ogni tanto vedo veicolo
richiede sei games
la juventus dice nero gran brune fantasy
va bene i ragazzi ogni volta che
qualcuno mi chiederà che cosa voglio
fare in futuro perché me lo chiedono
sempre tutti io risponderò voglio fare
le pubblicità però giapponesi io voglio
andare in giappone fare le pubblicità
per i giapponesi basta c'è qualcuno di
voi è giapponese assumetemi vengo gratis
[Musica]
cosa sul cosiddetto aiuto calmiamoci
riguardiamo un attimo la scena non c'e
uno che sta lavoro e si addormenta e
sogni a questo
[Musica]
spiegami che cosa ti sei fumato la sera
prima per lo spirito mani avanti
[Musica]
non capisco
come la tortura
non c'è questa che legge un notebook su
uno scivolo altissime maggio
[Musica]
robe tr'mon a caso ma di cosa stiamo
parlando di semplicità di notte di kart
o no non ho capito cosa sto vedendo la
storia de
nell'armadio fratello è giusto perché
nell'armadio c'è un ottimo sound cioè io
ad esempio sostanza qua sono quei
pannelli chiuso piccola perché almeno il
sound è buono 15 deteniene armadio e
schitarrate che va bene se io vedo
pilotarono altra parte della mia vita io
mi ammazzo
questa è la prima cosa che vi voglio
dire però il gatto merita ma vi prego
fate vivere il gatto a meta meta
pubblicità che meritava solo lui venisse
la faccia di quel gatto e la mia stessa
vitalità quando esco o in discoteca e mi
dicono di tenere il ritmo
[Musica]
sapete la cosa che ho notato in giappone
non è che i giapponesi in genere hanno
la faccia tonda gli adulti anche allora
la faccia che è tonda ok i bambini
essendo carini piccoli quindi hanno la
faccia tonda anno le guance che sono
così se volete un bambino giapponese
delle guance abnormi che mi mangerei
bambini giovani sono tipo caramelle che
schifo ma perché ci vedesse babbo gesù
che idea di cosa era qui stylist
knickers ma come farò fermi l'opera in
pista migliore del mondo del mondo
bellissima ma che idea splendida volete
è venuto in mente ragazzi non sono mai
pronto ok
mario tennis supermini ho capito solo
dopo un po solo perché la parola tennis
non è traducibile in giapponese e quindi
con stemmi mano e mario ai giochi
olimpici con luigi incastrato sul
pallone
mario tennis maria giochi litici varie
sonic ma era una bibita società oriente
porterò mio volume era una bibita la
coiro mario tennis mario e giochi
olimpici marius sdraiato sul divano no
era una bibita decapita questa invece mi
sarei pubblicità di dire non so perché
secolare primera nella città inglese
birra no lo svelto del lavandino non è
dirla sporca o forse sì o forse si
aspetta
no perché staccato ne vado di rapire non
si capisce se è una birra no è un fruit
vaso o mio dio bambino che ti spunta il
supermercato a caso con le guance rosse
a caldo ma si butta giù anche tutti i
santi ma stai tranquillo perché non ho
capito cosa era nudo herald erano di
noodle ok pure ragazzi una pubblicità su
due dei giapponesi sono o il mutolo
ramen l'altra è bieber con omaggi e
maggior rame in cui benissimo oddio
cereali a forma di supposta a forma di
garanzia forma di pinguino pesce ma duro
non sono scenari sono phoenix
la forma di animaletti stupidi ragazzi
io vorrei concludere facendomi vedere
una roba che non posso commentare perché
non è che mi difende però loro lo dicono
con la bocca
quindi io posso anche non dire niente
prego marecchia vedi ragazzi questa era
la pubblicità giapponesi di oggi spero
che vi siano piaciute a me molti ma
tanto ormai penso che non ci sia più
niente da spiegare e la perfezione spero
che vide gli sia piaciuto spero siano
state pubblicità di vostro gradimento io
comunque tra un po si ritornerà in
giappone farò pubblicità in live
giapponesi non vedo l'ora
se avete vissuto è stato un bel commento
fatemi sapere cosa tu dalla vostra
pubblicità preferita e noi come sempre
ci rivediamo ad un prossimo video bella
ragazza
[Musica]